I think we're all looking at Postmates
at the same time like I can anymore
right it's like I just I think I've been
through all of it yeah it's just I don't
want a container anymore I got lucky
with Postmates unlucky I guess where I I
tried to order booze I think this may
have been pre-pandemic or like just
during the pandemic and
I ordered booze from like a places like
you know a mile away yeah really late at
night and I accidentally hit pickup
uh-huh and then like it's ready and I'm
like oh no wait cancel get delivered
like no we already made it for you I
mean he didn't make it you like put it
in a box it's right there and it was a
lot of my I got this is a really nice
bottle of tequila right and just I
ordered the delivery and then I have my
business manager stop payment on that
one thing and they just said until you
pay this you can't use Postmates and so
I just been like it's the principle I'm
not gonna pay 200 bucks or whatever it
was yeah for that that I haven't used
Postmates since so I'm really stuck with
I'm sure one night I'll be in I'll be
somewhere on the road yeah and need
someone to get me a pizza at two in the
morning and I'll I'll pay that 200 bucks